amado o detestado con Silvio verlos con
y no hubo nunca términos medios
permaneció al frente de la política
italiana por más de dos décadas
sirviendo como Primer Ministro en cuatro
gobiernos durante 17 años y dejando tras
así un legado de controversia no fueron
los múltiples escándalos sexuales sino
la crisis económica y sus propios
problemas legales los que finalmente
acabaron con la era berlusconia en
Italia nació en 1936 en una familia de
clase media de Milán Se ganó un nombre
como cantante de un club nocturno pero
después estudiar leyes en la universidad
Amazon una inmensa fortuna como promotor
inmobiliario en 1978 dirigió sus
ambiciones hacia los medios italianos
lanzó una compañía de televisión por
cable Y utilizando sus conexiones
políticas la llevó a ser el más grande
imperio mediático del país eso combinado
con la propiedad del club de fútbol hace
Milan lo convirtió en un nombre familiar
así fue como ver luz con Y puso la mira
en la política definiéndose como un
liberal en 1993 formó su partido Fort
Italia que un año después ganaba las
elecciones generales a pesar de ser
multimillonario encontró la forma de
conectar con el votante común su primer
gobierno colapsó después de siete meses
pero verlos con y permaneció en
perturbable volvió a ser Primer Ministro
en 2001 y aunque salió del gobierno en
2006 ganó las elecciones para un tercer
y último mandato dos años después con el
tiempo los escándalos sexuales y las
acusaciones de corrupción le pasaron
factura las fiestas en su Villa
vulgarmente conocidas como las
bungabunga llegaron a los titulares de
todo el mundo y dañaron su popularidad
en casa en noviembre de 2011 la
maltrecha economía de Italia fue la gota
que rebosó el vaso en el pico de la
crisis de deuda de la eurozona verlos
con y renunció las esperanzas de regreso
Se frustraron en 2013 cuando fue
condenado por fraude fiscal expulsado
del parlamento y se le prohibió volver a
postularse ese mismo año fue hallado
culpable de pagar por tener sexo con una
menor una condena revocada en 2014 pero
la salida de la política no fue total en
2022 su partido Forza Italia formó parte
de una alianza de ultraderecha que llevó
al poder a Georgia malone a pesar de
décadas de altibajos Silvio roscón y
mantuvo el apoyo de miles e italianos
que han admirado su resiliencia su
controvertida faceta pública y su
liderazgo político